i appreciate you
talking to me about this it's such a
unusual
odd interesting story and way to present
a story like this
and and i i'm curious when you read the
script
was it pretty clear the vision of this
um no actually like i
i read the script and the script is
you know it is descriptive that later
became the movie but
reading it i was like oh this is so
strange
uh it's beautiful and it's posting all
these
important philosophical questions but
it's weird and
and i yeah it was a very hard time for
me actually envisioning exactly what the
result of the film
would become you know there's so many
different ways of doing this story
and it could it could have it could feel
more like a
weird sci-fi movie uh or something more
toned down and more
human which is the end result of the
film but i just didn't i
did not know what there's some scripts
that you read and you
you have a very clear sense of what the
results gonna be but not with this one
um and even shooting as well i was like
oh we're
figuring that out and for me i thought
that you know my
main objective being in this movie was
to support edson's vision how he wanted
it because he wrote it it was very part
personal story to him
that i was just like what is it that you
want to say with this and
i can use whatever tools that i have at
my disposal to
support that vision and then finally
seeing the movie
when it premiered in sundance i was
incredibly moved and
and impressed by by the end result of
the film
and and edson's vision coming to you
know coming to fruition and and
and also incredibly moved by all the the
actors that i
did not have scenes with uh but did get
to know during the shooting i mean we
were rehearsed for a few weeks and we
hung out
um and i thought that all the
performances were so stellar
that i had a very it was a very moving
experience finally seeing the result
one of the things that's so interesting
about this is that questions of
life in the universe make for big
concepts
but the approach of this really is very
small and intimate was that
something that ultimately surprised you
i mean you know you're talking about
these big concepts but you're sitting in
somebody's living room or i mean it's
just i thought that was such an
interesting aspect of the story
yeah yeah it really is and i think the
movie really benefits from it
that it is this very intimate portrait
of of humans really
even though that not really any
character is human apart from
from from will um
it you know there was always there were
these
aspects in the script as well for sure
and it was going to be this house filled
with
old you know old old
boxy televisions and and vhs's i was
like oh
it's very unique that way but um
but yeah and even in telling these sort
of last moments for all of these
candidates that he's recreating
something that
almost tastes like life for them for
their final moment before they
you know disappear into the oblivion
was minimalistic um in the script
um but um
but still i mean again it was surprised
seeing how how
how well it all came together and a high
concept
feeling that intimate and personal um
yeah it really moved me i'm guessing
that it's
a pretty rare opportunity to play a
character that's mostly a blank slate
he's this new soul that hasn't lived
before
how did you approach this character and
figuring out
who he is when you play someone that has
no past or backstory
where do you begin yeah i mean
and that was a you know
questions that i had even going into my
first meeting with edson
after reading the script i was like okay
how what's your
you know what what is your uh
thoughts and beliefs on these candidates
what are they
where did they come from or you know
there these are characters without
any past or any anything really
so they're all they're forming their
personality as you get to know them
um so the first week of rehearsal that
was something that i think
all of us playing the candidates were
all like okay what does all of this mean
like when i try an apple for the first
time what
what happens you know do you want a
sensation of like oh my god i feel taste
for the first time
and like you know uh or do you want
something where it's like oh yeah it's
almost like
they've been there before and and edson
wanted something that was
much more uh
you know naturalistic and and simpler
and more intimate
so which was like for me you know
my goal was just to support his vision
so whatever he wanted for it from it
right so uh and it's not that hard for
me
to do a character without you know a
back story per se
i i think that backstories that are not
in the scripts uh can sometimes be
overrated to have
at least if you really dig into it but
uh um
um but it was something where
what's the character what's his
i mean in a way the characters are sort
of these
personality archetypes so so um
leaning into that and and
the the answers for the characters are
instinctual
um not based of uh of or because of the
past so they're
instinctual so they're there's something
that what i could like
draw from so the question is and the
answer sort of
surprises the candidate it just comes
out automatic because there's no filter
to it
they are just what they are really um
but it was a challenge and it was also
it was also a lot of
fun you know um and uh and again it's
just like
for me every day i was like edson what
do you want what's your vision for this
it was such a personal story
to him he wrote the script so like
whatever he wanted i
i i tried to uh to give him
what was the production like on this was
this something where because
so much of it really is stripped down
without any bells and whistles
you only had to do a couple of takes of
each scene or was there more time
spent exploring things in the scenes
um yeah i mean most of it was shot
on the stage where they built the
interior of the house
um it was quite comfortable you know we
shot it in
in salt lake city in utah end of the
summer september
at times it was really hot but then the
longer we went into the production to
kind of cool down to a beautiful
you know early fall there um and um
and yeah you know we we in the beginning
was more about exploring because i was
like edson i could give you
a lot of different things here for the
character like uh
weirder things if you wanted something
that's more sci-fi-esque or something
or performance is being more abstract
because the movie's abstract but again
he didn't want that so
so then it became to you know finding
that right tone
um and um and yeah
and still exploring and sometimes it was
like you know figuring it out and
as soon as edson felt that he had
something we we moved on
um like the only day for me at least
that took a really long time was like
the dinner scene towards the end of the
film um
was you know a lot of coverage and and
um and sort of a camera rig that would
like circle around us
and all of that but other than that you
know it's
a lot of most of my scenes were just me
and
um winston and classic coverage and
we we got to uh to have fun with it
there's been some talk about you joining
john wick 4
is that true yeah
that's true what made you want to do
that i mean are you
secretly you know do you want to be an
action star like what uh
what was the attraction to that um
i think the movies are very entertaining
um
i've always been a fan of these kind of
over-the-top
um um you know
exploitive action movies um
and um and yeah chad reached out to me
and i
i've met him a few times and i really
like him
and it was a really fun role i mean
i'm not going to go into detail of what
it is but it's
it was just a fun role in a fun world
where
um i i like the movies i think they're
entertaining and it is something that i
haven't really done before so that's
always something that
that does inspire me um for whatever it
is it's like
okay this is a project or a genre or
something that i haven't done
so let's let's try it out and let's have
fun
uh within within those sort of genre
constraints
so um so yeah yeah i'm really looking
forward to it
how do you think the action will compare
to stuff that you've done before i mean
we've seen the kind of action those
films have to offer is it something that
you'll have to train a lot for
um no not for
for like i'll again i will get into a
detail for it
but but yeah i mean again it's just it's
something different and so that's why i
wanted to do it
um like i think that um this
i've had it for a very long time like i
want i want to
be so try to be as versatile as i
possibly can
whether it is crossing genres or
or playing just these vastly different
characters
um so um you know actually just finished
a horror film but
but like i feel like the horror genre is
something that i've done a lot of so
so you know you know
i like to do comedies i like to do
action i like to do
as much as possible and i think that
that's sort of a
key to a long to a long longevity
in in this business in in having a fun
career where you can go like oh i can do
a lot of different things
so you don't end up find becoming you
know limited into this box
uh which happens all the time
you know the industry itself is like
whatever is the
your last big success that's what they
think that you are so
oh he's great at being you know freaky
monsters so
then it's like freaky monsters is your
type and you're like wait a minute like
i can do a lot more than that so
i'm just trying to do very you know as
many
different types of roles and projects as
as i can
as long as there's something that i find
interesting and fun
uh in the character that's how i respond
to it and i'm like oh i can do something
with this
that that i
that inspires me so um so yeah
basically it's as simple as that did you
with nine days did you have
conversations with edson about
why this guy was ultimately the one who
was chosen
yeah yeah and i mean it had less to do
with
me and more to do with winston's
character and will
who who ultimately comes up with that
position um
and um you know there's
i think that there were i
don't want to break you should actually
ask them this question because
there's there's certain moments in
the script that makes will make this
decision that he
ends up making um and they're very
specific
um and that had more to do
with will than it had to do with me uh
like uh um and um
for why making that call i thought it
was very strong because it
the the there's a the critique that the
movie has
to this kind of harsh
um an unforgiving world that we live in
becomes
stronger with that ending i thought um
so there was a there was a i thought
there was a point
um for the movie to end that way as well
as as you know the reasons for why will
ultimately makes that call
yeah i thought it was so interesting i
mean obviously when you watch the whole
movie you really get a sense of why that
decision
was made i just i think it's so
interesting
because there are so many layers you
realize how many layers of things are
actually going on
something that seems so simple yeah
yeah and uh and again i mean i think
that the
i hope that people that walk out of the
theater after they've seen this film
you know go and have a drink and then
try to dissect it and talk about it and
i think that
a lot of people will have very different
opinions on it as well it becomes
like this the film itself um
you know invites a
spiritual and philosophical conversation
afterwards
so people might be upset about certain
things and like oh and then that can
lead into an argument
and then i can you know build a
conversation and conversation starter
um which which i think the movie has and
that and i
i you know the that's a great part
of uh of great films
is that people talk about them
think about them and care about them
afterwards
well i appreciate you talking to me
about this one i just
i think that it's one of those things
that could have endless conversations so
i appreciate it
no thank you